And finally, to end this
piece of the tutorial,
I'd like to encourage you
to use your imagination.
Think of lighting that's not
necessarily in the textbooks.
LOOK AT THIS FOR
EXAMPLE: It's a device
that you'll be
seeing a great deal
of in our virtual
tool of lighting,
which you'll get to later.
I did not place it
on the lightbox;
I used the lightbox
as a light source
as you see in this image.
Because of its
transparency and --
its actually quite beautiful
just as something itself --
I put it on my flatbed scanner.
But, this is not
a scanned image.
I'm actually using the light
from the flatbed scanner,
as you can see in this image.
Sometimes it could
work if you get light
from the side in this case.
And another idea that perhaps
you haven't thought about
is to use a small
L-E-D flashlight
if you want to image a very
small area of your device.
Here we're just
photographing the spiral,
which measures about 2 and
a half centimeters across.
All I did was shined and L-E-D
flashlight onto that area.
Around the area, we
get lighting fall-off,
so we decided to only image this
particular piece in the device.
This is the image I started
making from a material called
Ferrofluid.
And what you're
seeing, actually,
is a close shot
of this material.
It is oil that has suspended
in it iron filings.
I put it in a glass slide.
Under the glass slide
is a yellow post-it,
and under the yellow post-it
are 7 circular magnets.
And you're seeing the
small iron particles
respond to the magnets.
It's basically too tight a
shot to see anything of value.
In this image, I
pulled away a bit,
and I see a little a little
more of what's going on,
but basically the
window panes become
maybe too much of a distraction
and it's not quite right.
And so I decided,
seeing how reflective
the whole image could be, to
put a green card above it.
So now we're seeing a little
bit of green reflecting off
of the material.
It is just purely an
aesthetic decision;
it's not clarifying anything.
But I'm starting to
think that I might
have an interesting image here.
And, eventually, I did wind
up with this final image:
With the window pane; with
the green card reflecting;
and, if you really
look carefully,
you see the mistake
of a bad photographer,
because you see me.
Although, it's fun to
play with the children
and asking them
to "Find Felice."
But this is an image
that got a lot of notice
when I made it a while ago.
And I was using my
imagination in terms
of trying to find a-a
way of using light
in perhaps a different way.